well when my staff found out that you
are going to be here
they freaked uh do you mind if one of my
producers
asks you a question because she really
wants to
not at all i'd love that okay awesome
please
everybody welcome senior associate
producer jasmine steven everybody
give it up for jasmine
so jasmine you're a massive kpop fan i
did not know that this is awesome
absolutely like i have been known to
like call out of work
just to fly across the country to go see
axe i didn't do that here i promise you
but like i've done it before well now we
know where you're gonna be
jasmine so what would you want to ask
rosie
so rose as you know i'm a huge fan of
yours but i love your puppy hank he is
so
cute so i just want to know what's his
favorite food
what's his favorite color and can i be
his best friend and then additionally if
i can be his best friend can i be his
godparent she is getting
in there she wants it all rosette
anytime i would love that um
i mean hank is like the cutest puppy i
adopted him i
actually um so in korea there's like a
bunch of people who upload
these um puppies who um are up for
like adoption and um they kind of don't
have a home and
so um i saw him online and this lovely
lady was
kind of posting about him um telling
people to you know adopt
not buy and um i fell in love with him
and he's just so adorable like you said
he does
like he's very good with tricks if i say
nose he would go ahead and like poke his
nose through my um
fingers and uh his favorite food
is uh his favorite food just any type of
dog snack we give him like all these
treats um
he just likes anything to be honest
anything that's related to eating
um and yeah his favorite color i have no
idea
[Laughter]
you'll have to ask yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever